yo let's talk because i feel like
i'm glad to see that like some of these
wild like accusations that were thrown
your way
have been cleared up right but i feel
like
as men in 2022
it's unfortunate that like somebody
could just lie on your name and it's on
you
to shake that you know what i'm saying
talk about what happened and just like
how you've been dealing with that [ __ ]
because
you know the truth your team knows the
truth the [ __ ] law knows the
truth right
but once like your mug shot goes up in a
certain manner on some of these blog
sites you have like you have that
certain [ __ ] that you gotta shake
yourself right
basically [ __ ] [ __ ] just lied
i'm guessing you know gotta be over the
money [ __ ] but want some money probably
and i'm not the type of dude who you can
you know blackmail a black ball or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it so
you have to go with your move
and i'm guessing um
[ __ ] she probably
oh she's coaching the mic if you can
shut your phone off all right go ahead
man oh i'm guessing like
she thinking that she won't make the
allegation uh she was gonna go
fast and all this other [ __ ] she didn't
know the police had a whole type of
different
uh swing gave me for they on purpose so
[ __ ]
it took longer than what she thought i
guess she thought i was gonna reach out
and try to come come uh drop her back to
get it to go away yeah and i'm not that
type of [ __ ] and uh [ __ ] that's just
what it is
i let the loud uh put it into the low
hands she had dna came back all that
type [ __ ]
everything they just caught up in all
the [ __ ] lies she did yeah cause like
most people like you said
she probably figured if i throw this on
him people just want to pay to get it to
go away correct but i feel like if you
do that while it might be less of a
headache it also feels like
damn maybe he did do something and if
you are real if you're innocent you're
like nah [ __ ] that let's see this [ __ ]
through because i you ain't going to
deal with that headache which i
understand with me i don't give a [ __ ]
about that like i'm not
you're not going the black bomb if you
want to try to
say i gotta give you 10 15 20 000 or
whatever you're not saying that's what
right what she was on but you know what
i'm saying like if that's what this is
going to be baby you have to work your
move yeah and i'm different not doing it
because i'm i'm knowing like [ __ ] that
ain't me by far 100
um has it uh
negatively affected you at all in terms
of just like in a corporate world y'all
kind of you know people want to back up
and see how the [ __ ] play out before
they just you know i'm saying either
stick with you or do some business with
you for sure right yeah because i feel
like um
like i said man it's unfortunate because
it's it's
do you always see the the accusations
printed in big headlines
but when it gets cleared up it ain't as
big of a story because it ain't as juicy
that's why you got to go on your own
press runs and you have to really just
put this [ __ ] together for your own
benefit and pray because they'll leave
your ass hide and drive for sure 100
percent
the room's going to spread 10 times
faster than truth